here on generation next our weekly uh
forward-looking video game and console
show we have two nicknames for you
and uh we'd like you to pick the
official nickname for generation next
the first one is big phil which is a
great one i like it a lot
it's based on a very awkward dating
moment where a guy
comes up and says my name is phil but my
friends call me big phil and we've
called you big phil since then
and the other one because of the power
of game pass and your efforts to get
many games on there is feel sponsors
um so whenever we have it
[Laughter]
so which one do you like
i guess if those two i'd have to go with
big phil but
i'd rather people just call me phil uh
on p3
on on xbox live you know people but
i guess i'm appreciated i appreciate
that i'm being mentioned anyway so
it's almost weekly and it's casually
like yeah but you know big phil said
on twitter and uh the audience seems to
love it and it's picky okay
we'll go with that all right cool uh
official big phil is the official
nickname for our show
one thing i want to talk about is the
identity of xbox as you currently see it
um i think you've been very candid and
it's been refreshing to see
um you say you know it was kind of a
wayward time at the start of the xbox
one
and then you along with a bunch of other
people on your team kind of started to
find an
identity for it um from your perspective
do you think you've found that identity
now um
how do you currently see the xbox of
today when i think about our identity
i do think as a team we feel our
identity so internally and i've talked
previously about you know after the xbox
one launch
the team was a little wayward trying to
figure out what do we stand for
are we tb tv to be like what are we what
are we about and i
i think what the team has really
centered around is
listening to our customer putting our
customer at the center i mean even early
decisions around user voice
and being very doing our monthly updates
with our platform i mean you remember
all of this stuff
but it was really about what are the
things that our customers want
sometimes even asking the customers will
ask things that aren't
in the near term the best thing for our
platform but we think about the long
term making the customer decisions or
the right decisions when we can
um i mean on and on the external side i
think the identity is still something
that's evolving because we're doing
something different um
we're not doing the traditional build a
console go take your old console and put
it in the closet and there's
four or five new games for the new
console and you forget about the old
stuff and you only play with people who
have the new thing
you know we're we think about xbox more
as an ecosystem as a platform across
many screens
and that can be confusing um because
it's different
and uh so i think that journey it's
beholden on us
to explain what does this mean and why
is it good for a player it can't just be
good for us
it's also got to be good for players so
you know that's worked for
for us to continue to do so on the
external side i think there's still
journey for us
how much of that is like clear in your
mind or and how much is it like rolling
with the punches and figuring out is it
is it smart to have a set plan and go
this is what we're shooting for or is it
smarter in this day and age to look at
the demands of the world around you the
people playing your games and
the kind of various businesses that feed
into it and then
kind of roll with it as it happens i
think it's both actually i think it's
important for the team that we have a
longer term plan that we can talk
about because some of the incremental
engineering decisions or even business
decisions that we make
have years to play out and we're lucky
that we work at a company like microsoft
that
is supporting our multi-year ambitions
like xcloud
and and will get behind those things so
you have to have a long-term vision on
where you're going
otherwise you just are kind of misguided
in the decisions that you're making
but every day we learn we learn new
things
and when we learn new things we have to
react to those i can remember back in
the day
on the console i'll be sitting around
the leadership team as they had a first
party at the time
and there was a real kind of worry that
free to play would be the death of
consoles
and you know you you saw like oh these
big freedom claim games on pc and mobile
we can't let those on console
that was kind of from the top down the
prevailing philosophy
and now you look at consoles and free to
play does incredibly well on console it
hasn't been the death of the console if
anything you could say it's helped grow
and that's because players were playing
and eventually you don't
you can't ignore what players are doing
in fact you should embrace
what players want to do and i think
that's pretty
critical so it's a little bit of both
long-term navigation and near-term
having your eyes open and listening and
watching so one of the big discussion
points around the series x and series s
which are out very soon um is the launch
lineup and you've
indicated previously that game pass is
basically your
big launch lineup uh thing right given
the library
it's certainly a compelling one but is
there a worry
that no there's no big showpiece for
what the console can
do um the ui and the navigation stuff
like someone who's used it and
the features the hardware have are doing
a lot of heavy lifting in that regard
and they have
a definite wow factor um but
is there a concern that there's not one
game where you can put in and be like
holy moly this is it this is the next
gen clearly
in terms of the dialogue you and i were
have or that
you know some kind of the i'll say more
traditional way of looking at a console
launch
it's one of the things that people are
looking at i think there's some great
games to go look at when you look at the
games that are launching right now
i played all weekend playing ac valhalla
and i think you know the team at ubisoft
had done a great job
i think about watchdog legions which
frankly isn't a franchise i play to tama
tana but i really am i'm enjoying this
game
i'm playing tetris effect i'm playing
games but that's not to dissuade like
you know we've been clear i wanted a
halo game at the launch of the console
but i will say that was more emotional
than business driven like we're going to
be sold out of consoles come tomorrow
and um and that doesn't make me happy i
wish we had more consoles i wish we
could
supply all of the demand that will be
out there so i think from a pr
standpoint it would be nice because
people could write about you know a
couple of good games
from a business standpoint i'm not
overly worried about it and
frankly when those games will come i
think will be a good opportunity for the
console when we're really in more of a
competitive battle
because there's consoles from different
uh from us and sony on the shelf
so you mentioned it game pass is the
thing that i really think differentiates
our console platform right now
and we've got 50 million subscribers
doing incredibly well a great collection
of games from so many partners
our launch games go in day and date so
gears tactics these
games people who haven't played before
can go play
um so i feel really really good about
the investment
in game pass and how that stands up
against any competitive offering app
that's out there
and i guess the one plus side is it
gives people more of an inclination to
buy yakuza which is a
fantastic franchise finally on xbox at
the go
finally that's right the killer the
killer app launch title for experts
everyone should play it so um you
mentioned like you know um
they will come eventually do you how
soon do you think it will be
before we start to see those kind of
games that you know really leverage the
s and the x
architecture and is there an urgency
within the company to
get there as soon as possible or is it
very much a case of
take your time do it right we've got
game pass we can
we can ride that um kind of like the
benefits of that for a while and to to
give you the space you need
yeah i'll start with the the
differentiation because
and we've said and i i think we've said
for a while
that this generation's leap is going to
be more about feel than look
and i believe that um and that's
something that doesn't show up on a
video
it's hard right to give people a sense
of well what does 60
feel like compared to 30 what does 120
feel like compared to 60
what do these load times really mean in
terms of the instant access to the games
that you want to go play are nearly
instant
access to the games that you want to
play you've used the console so you get
a feel for it
over time but we've talked about that
actually for a couple years that
we're gonna start to feel game they feel
as good as games have looked because you
know an xbox one x has done a really
good job
allowing developers to to put amazing
looking games on screen so i think the
leap
will be gradual as it is in most
generations because developers will
get used to the tools at the same time
we've seen some really great
work on pc so people know what these
high graphic bar games are going to look
like when they come to console
games like a flight sim which will come
to cons low you know when that comes
to xbox series x it's going to look
fantastic um
i've been very focused on on how things
play and how they feel and i love the
work that like moon has done with ori
and coalitions done with gears in terms
of pressure on the teams there's always
pressure on the teams but it's more
self-inflicted
we have as you said we have game pass
we've got a lot of support from the
company
i don't need to push half done games
out i can make sure that we get to the
point where we really believe in where
we are with the game
um and some of those games will continue
to grow after they launch
and and feel good about that so
definitely want to make sure we get the
games right
more than hit an individual date that
leads as a perfect segue into halo you
mentioned it earlier like you wanted it
from there
from the start as an emotional thing and
not having it is obviously a big loss so
um what is your kind of view on that
franchise
as it stands do you still feel like it
is the
juggernaut in entertainment that it was
in the 360 days i remember seeing you
know
the the incredible numbers around you
know three and
and and the other games that were around
the 360. do you still feel it has
that power i definitely think it has the
potential for that power
um i think there's something iconic
about bungie's creation originally about
master chief
you know i teasingly call him john wayne
in space but like this
you know this iconic character hero
character
that i think people are drawn to um
and when i look at how well master chief
collection has done say as it's gone to
pc
um and as 343's continue to evolve it
even now for
um xbox series x and series s there's
high level of interest with high level
of interest comes a lot of pressure on
the team
comes a lot of emotion when we don't hit
a date that we wanted to hit
i take all of that emotion and feel that
i have as a positive sign for the
franchise
that said there are a lot more big
franchises now in gaming than there were
back when halo 1 2 and 3 launched and i
think that's a good thing for our
industry and a good thing for xbox the
fact that we can have
a diversity of franchises and what those
mean
um so i don't think a platform has to
define we get that you know who's your
iconic character on a platform i think
you are
the iconic character on our platform
it's not any one of our individual
franchises and
um and i think that's a strength but i
have a ton of belief in halo and 343 and
where we're going and
i've played quite a bit of infinite and
i'm looking forward to other people
getting to play
when you said you are the iconic uh
mascot firefighter i thought you were
talking to me and i got very close
oh okay okay here's me awesome sweet
sweet so like the interesting thing i
found about halo i've been thinking
about a lot recently is
it's kind of it feels almost like its
existence and the way
its health is almost tied to the way
xbox is like in the time when
halo when xbox was trying to struggle to
find this identity
the same seemed to have happened to halo
you know the post bungie days
they kind of run parallel together now
that you're you know xboxes seems
to be on a more steady footing are you
what you're seeing in halo infinite is
it does it start to look like halo is
also starting to
you know get on steady footing and build
up momentum to be back in that good
space
i definitely think 343 has a clear
vision for what
they want the franchise to be and where
it goes and
and it's it's an interesting spot when
you have such a franchise with
tens of millions of customers fans who
just love the franchise
and yet the state of the art and gaming
continues to move on so you're in this
interesting world of wanting to balance
the old and the new
but yeah i feel really good about the
team and the vision that they have
for where halo can go i think one of the
things that
this is i'll put this on me i'm the head
of the business
i think there were certain people that
were looking for halo infinite to be
this
life-like gritty real world looking game
when we first shown it and
for those of us that have been around
halo for a long time that's never been
halo
you know halo's never been it's it's
always had a certain palette and a
certain look
and i actually think there's more games
in the industry now
that are it's less about how realistic
or how m can i make a game
and more about the fun and the
engagement that games have and that's
where i really think that infinite
infinite's gonna shine
i i really love the halo franchise and
i've enjoyed aspects of it but when i
think about it like my intense love of
halo and passion
is still very much rooted in one two
three odsd and reach like that kind
those kind of games
so for me it's starting to kind of feel
like a make or break moment for the
franchise do you think that's
fair to say um do you what what does
what do you and what do
343 see as the stakes for infinite well
it's interesting even going back let me
just
go because i'm i'm right now playing
through reach on legendary with a friend
we're playing through co-op
um and four of us just did this on with
odst
and you know i was here when reach and
odst
launched and i think it's fair to say
they were not
universally embraced uh when they
launched um for the people who had you
know two and then
three because they were a little bit
different you know where's master chief
as the central character
in the case of odst who are these
orbital drop shot troopers and where's
where are my spartans um and now when
you go back
like you mentioned them in the same
breath with one two three you instantly
go to reach in odst
and i even start to feel that about four
like i'll get some commentary now that
people love the story and four they
wanted multiplayer to be better
then when they go to five many people
say five was the best multiplayer in the
franchise they wanted the story to be
better
but i think there is something kind of
historical
that people will look back on the games
when they first come out their certain
expectations
but then over time i think certain games
especially in the halo franchise become
beloved even if they weren't
universally embraced when they come out
so i don't look at any one of these
individual launches
infinite included and say there's some
kind of make or break because i just
don't think entertainment works that way
do i think master chief and the the
challenge that we put him in in the
games has an enduring
quality and something that will be
around for decade plus absolutely
um is it beholding on us to treat that
franchise in
the stories and the characters the right
way yes and listen to our customers
absolutely but i i think halo is around
for a long time
um kind of you know an infinite will be
a great beat
in the halo lore i'd like to make a
request on behalf of all halo fans can
we get
a reversible cover for halo infinite
when it comes out with craig on the
other side
um i know everyone loves master chief
but i think the new era of halo is tied
up in
cake we actually have these t-shirts i
didn't wear it today which is craig's
face
i love how they even embrace that you
know it's just so
so funny uh yeah i think craig will be
around
for for many many decades in the halo
lore you'll find his pictures all over
the place yeah
probably in game somewhere you know
it'll be funny i can only hope
um the other thing about uh halo is
there's been a level of staff turnover
and changes at
343 um this year and obviously when
people see that you get armchair
analysts and you get various people
starting to worry and um can you give us
like a status update on
the game in the team there um and is the
the turnover something that
we should be worried about yeah i think
this has been this has been a long
project
and um i think we've added people to the
team when i think about pierre and i
think about joe coming on to the team
um sometimes what hits the press or when
certain things get announced
internally have actually happened months
before so it's not always true it's not
always
accurate that when these things line up
we did take
the feedback coming out of the july
showcase event
seriously uh both on the date and what
people were expecting from the game
you know it was a miss on our part on my
part
to open our july showcase with halo
infinite
and then a couple weeks later have to
move the date like that
i don't take the sentiment and the
emotion of our fans and our customers
lightly and when we get into a situation
where we set an expectation that here
this is something you're going to have
at launch
and then we have to change that
expectation not to
you know much after our showing that's a
mistake
and that's something that we really
can't do so
um i really have a lot of faith in
bonnie and the team there
um having joe and pierre join which they
did
pretty early in the this or late in the
summer
i feel good about where we are on that
team but as an industry we're always
going to see turnover
um and i wouldn't think i don't have any
specific concern about 343 i actually
think in the long run
turnover is a healthy thing because you
want people who are really motivated
by the things that they're working on i
guess um broadly looking at your kind of
portfolio now how much of a push for
diversity is there in in the genres that
you guys are tackling right now
um you've got a bunch of studios but um
obviously i have
less insight than you do but they kind
of to me fit the the shooter mold and in
the rpg mold
um a lot of them and i think back to the
days of like having viva pinata
alongside perfect dark alongside cameo
alongside all these kind of
various different styles of games do you
think you're moving towards that now
with
with the kind of the kind of
acquisitions that you've made and is
that something that you want or is it a
case of
just make what you're good at well i do
want people to make what they're good at
so then the question is as we think
about
how we grow studios with matt booty and
i do we look for teams that are
different are good at things that are
different than what our current
stable of studios have as skills
and i think you point out something
that's right that we
when we looked even at the zenimax you
know acquisition which
obviously we've announced that it's not
closed um we didn't look at that and say
okay this diversifies our portfolio from
like a
color tone or a rating standpoint you
know
but i thought it was some really really
talented teams that we wanted to go work
with
when i think about forward going forward
i do
think we need different genres different
color palettes different
stories different game ratings coming
from different parts of the world i
think that's an important
next step for us when we look at
opportunities now some of the
opportunities are inbound some of us are
us reaching out
so you don't always get to pick exactly
the game that's coming
you know i'm excited about games like
psychonauts and what double fine is
going to go do
beyond even what psychonauts is but it's
unfair to put all the weight on one
studio to say okay
um you're our non-m rated studio
um so yeah i think you point out a good
issue for us
and something that's an opportunity
whether it's through third-party
partnerships
um or whether it's through things that
we can do in our first party to make
sure we have a diverse set of games for
all kinds of people
that is one area where i think game pass
really works when i sit in a game pass
and i look at the portfolio of games
and i think about game pass as just a
part of our platform
so when you become a member of of xbox
so many of those people join game bass
and when we think about the portfolio of
games that we're adding to game pass i'm
really pleased by
the diversity of stories characters
color palettes ratings that i see
and that's something that we'll continue
to push for i mean you mentioned new
opportunities before and
uh your first party there was a report
recently from bloomberg
which said that several japan-based devs
have been approached about acquisition
is there any truth to that
i don't think so like it's we're usually
not
out there i say i don't think so i mean
i'm not in every meeting that every team
has
but i'll say not from me um you know
it's
most of the opportunities that we've had
to date have been a long-lasting
relationship
um and so you know i don't think we're
out there with
you know our business card throwing them
out on the corner uh trying to find
people i've i've
talked about my affinity for japanese
studios and
thinking back in the day when we had
more games that were created in japan as
part of our first party
um i'm excited when the deal closes to
get to spend more time with tango and
this work that they're doing
um but you know so it's an area that i'm
interested in but
no i don't think it's i think that's not
accurate
okay that's good to know um how uh
going off of that sticking with japan a
bit or just the the region like how
valuable is the asian market to you um
and what does what does xbox look like
there
do you see any value there if any
absolutely yeah
um and i'm glad you say you know the
asian market and when i talk about the
asian market from a gaming standpoint
the major markets in asia are actually
very very different from one another if
you look at the japanese markets very
different than the korean market
very different from the chinese market
in the southeast asian market
you know in the case of korea we've
launched xcloud there
and a majority of the people that are
part of game pass right now are actually
x cloud members in korea
um they're not people who are playing on
pc or playing on console they're
actually members of game pass
through console so that's through uh
through the cloud
and i think that's an interesting inroad
in certain markets same thing with our
pc focus and game pass on pc
and our first party games that are there
you know i also have an affinity for all
the amazing creators that are in japan
and it's
i spent a lot of time there and i want
to make sure those creators see xbox as
a great place for their games and when i
think about things like kingdom hearts
and yakuza and other games that we've
been able to see
come to the platform this generation so
it's both a third party focus
and a first party focus and the
different asian markets are different
and we will approach them differently um
but absolutely they are important i will
say
they're not you know i don't think i'm
gonna go into japan and outsell
the japanese console makers with with
xbox um i would hope to i would like to
but it's it's not in the the plan that
i've written down but we're going to
work really hard
to have the best generation that we've
ever had in japan
um and the same thing in korea and china
and i feel good about our opportunity
there um and especially when i think
about
fans of our platform outside of those
markets who want to play games that come
from those
those countries that's a commitment i
want to make as well
does it feel like to you you're in a
better position to do that in japan and
asia because you know
the when the when the xbox one launched
it was all entertainment focused it was
this giant
chunky console that takes up a lot of
space and
you know it was a very certain type of
person wanted it and
it didn't jive with japan right and now
you have this console that's
well at least you have one console
that's very small the other one it
doesn't have a massive footprint either
um and also you know cloud gaming is
hooked into with xcloud
does it feel like you're in a position
where like do you feel compelled to take
another big shot at it even if history
has shown that xbox doesn't
have a huge foothold in asia and japan
well
i was i was just thinking that our
tagline for the xbox one when we
launched it was big chunky platform
i mean the thing to remember about the
launch of xbox one is we actually didn't
launch in those markets when we launched
in the us
and the uk and other markets and you
know fans and customers of ours there
saw that and it clearly showed a lack of
appreciation and support for those
markets for our platform and
so starting from let's make sure that
we're launching
um in all the markets where we want to
have the console kind of globally at the
same time just to show respect
for the customers there that was
important i absolutely feel like
um we're going to continue to make a a
good
i feel like we've we've got the best
opportunity we've ever had in
a generation to do well in those markets
we
our pre-order in japan sold out almost
instantly
our pre-order numbers exceeded our xbox
one sales for the previous
year that was our pre-order on that one
day so when you just think about the
volume and the interest that's there
um and that's specific to japan and like
i said when i think about xcloud and how
that's doing in
in korea um when i think about the china
market with pc and other things that
we're doing i feel like we are
better positioned because we're less
reliant on any one specific device
and as you mentioned even in the console
space we have series s
uh which i think you know clearly has a
design
and form factor and price point um that
we believe can do well it's going to be
about the games
which is why we continue to spend time
in japan with our partners there
um and getting games like fantasy
starring kuza and other games coming to
the platform
more work to do there um it's kind of
never where we'll never be done with
that
but i feel good about the opportunity
ahead absolutely yeah
as someone who loves japanese games and
is also heavily invested in xbox i think
the
the thing that i see is like it feels
like
japanese developers because of the
global market japanese developers
are more valuable to outside of the
country than xbox might be within it
like
namely bringing their games to us is
perhaps more valuable than try and force
you know
a presence in that area and it
definitely feels like you're doing that
with like stuff like pso bringing that
over
was a big deal which leads me to my next
question is what are the chances we'll
get a lost odyssey 2 from miss walker
because i'm desperate we need it
you know miss walker's in a much
different place i think if we were ever
going to go back and do something with
uh hello i worked on the first loss
odyssey um fantastic game
you know we'd have to almost recreate
all all that that means
uh but i actually just love when i think
about blue dragon lost odyssey
you know past games that we've built
it's not lost on me that tetris defect
is one of our launch games with us now
and it's uh mizuguchi that we're working
with we've worked with for
for many many years you know the the
relationships we have there
stuff things that we've had to rekindle
over the last few years
and build trust to your point about our
console success
i'll say this to somebody who goes and
plays a lot of games with my friends
there and stuff
in japan the fact that nobody owned an
xbox this last generation
meaning the people working on the games
was a challenge
for me because like you know just it was
out of sight out of mind
um so when i see things like us
pre-orders going well
um i want to be part of the gaming
consciousness
in japan even if uh you know
even if we don't win or whatever that
means
i need to be part of the consciousness i
need to be innovative i need to do
things that engage those developers i
need them to find success
globally with the franchises that we're
building and that's the area i've been
most proud of the team's work on the
ground there it's not always been easy
being part of
team xbox sitting in japan it hasn't
been over the last
you know decade or so but i feel good
about the progress we're making and i
think it shows
when you look at our last e3 shows uh
you know miyazaki's showing his games on
our stage and
somebody who's just an incredible
creator that works with sega to work
with capcom
work with bandai namco that we've had
work with square
it's been uh really good and and really
gratifying to see the progress
how much of olden ring have you seen can
you tell me anything
i've seen actually quite a bit i've
played quite a bit uh
oh i can't tell you i can't uh i can't
tell you much
other than as somebody's played all of
miyazaki's games over
at least the last decade um this is
clearly the most ambitious game
that he's done i mean you know it's and
i i love his games
but like seeing some of the even
gameplay mechanics stuff that he's
tackling
he and the team are tackling this time
the setting working with
another creator in terms of story and uh
i love it i love him seeing him
challenging himself expanding he's a
good friend of mine
expanding his his horizons i think it's
it's a good thing i know he's
he has when he has me play i go over he
has to leave the room he doesn't want to
well i think that's because i'm a bad
player but you know
and then he comes back and then we'll
have a conversation about things that i
think it's just
he's so passionate about what he does
it's one of the things i just love about
getting to work with
with him on some of these games and
seeing them come to our platform
that's awesome okay live services are
games are all the rage easy to access
titles that you can play
together like you know jackpots are all
the rage yeah we had hq trivia proved to
be a major success
i ask you big phil is it time for one
versus 100 to return
if not now when i am a big fan
of one versus 100 and chris charlie and
i have had many many
discussions on this topic i know i
teased it a little bit a couple weeks
ago
um i wouldn't tease people if i didn't
think that that was
something whether it's that exact ip
there's some things with that ip if
people know about it came from a game
show from one of our
tv networks here uh but the mechanic of
people playing online
and i thought was and just the whole
structure of that was really neat
and special maybe ahead of its time
getting to work on that was fun
i regret that we didn't keep it going so
um
you know i can't announce anything here
uh but i'll just say a big fan of what's
going on there and chris and i
are uh we're on the case i'll put it
that way awesome
uh final question uh one of the most
refreshing things about the new consoles
both the playstation 5 and the xbox
series x
and s is the obvious lack of gimmicks
it's they're not trying to do anything
big um anything
or that rocks the boat too much they
know what they do they can do well and
they lean into it
do you think the lack of hardware
gimmicks speaks to
a kind of confidence the industry now
has in itself
um and in what it does well what do you
think that means
like the the lack of a connect and the
lack of trying to introduce some weird
wow factor
into consoles means for yourself and the
other
console manufacturers well i think you
mentioned it that earlier on the
the games have really become the global
phenomena
it's not a game behold into a specific
gimmick on a specific platform though
some of those games
and learnings i think have been
fantastic and still permeate what we do
today
but really the games are the star and as
we're talking about earlier people
playing on many many screens
i mean it's really the innovation that
happens on software
and the kind of unique things that games
are doing to bring people together
and trying to build hardware innovation
that supports that
kind of pushes against this i'm gonna go
create a game that clearly could only
run on this one piece of hardware
because of some specific hardware
differentiation that you should create
because some of the biggest games in the
world are playable on a switch and a pc
and a playstation and xbox and now more
and more being streamed by us
and other big you know tech companies
i think what you're going to see is
really the game innovation be the thing
that leads and hardware supporting that
innovation through the tight
relationships that we have created with
the creators and i think that's a good
thing
quick follow-up uh yeah have you have
you played a playstation 5 what do you
think of it
um have i played a playstation 5 to be
careful on this one
um i will say what happens i haven't
played a retail playstation 5 so i don't
have one
right um what happens when we go into
studios is there's development kits from
all the platforms around so like we all
kind of know what we're all doing
yeah and i've definitely played games i
think you know sony's done a really nice
job with the playstation 5
i think the plans they're doing
something different than us
uh which is fine i think it's good that
you have different platforms
um doing different things i know their
launch is imminent i will i'll say good
luck to jim
and mark and all the teams there because
launches are you know kind of cool of
great events and
and congratulations to the team there
and what they've done so
um but i and no i haven't i don't have a
retail unit
uh yet i will get one and uh and i look
forward to it
well phil congratulations to you and the
team as well
you know um like you said launches are a
big deal and i'm excited for you guys
i'm excited to have an xbox
for the first time in a long time my one
was kind of
falling a bit to the wayside but now i
turn my xbox on every day and i'm having
a great time with it and i'm sure a lot
of people will feel the same
and i want to thank you for taking the
time out of your busy schedule to talk
to us it's much appreciated and your
uh canada has been super super valuable
thanks tim it's fun and uh everybody
this week be patient be safe as you're
trying to get consoles
uh wear your mask socially distance and
have a great time with
your new platforms if you get one
[Music]
you